I just got out was control yourself Big
Ang makes her final Mob Wives appearance
when ang came in it was like she changed
the whole dynamic of the group because
it went from the change we were gonna
kill each other then you came like this
peacemaker and you were funny and you
were just fighting then we had a good
time
vh1 aired at Mob Wives the final
sit-down Wednesday night the reunion was
dedicated to ang who died at just two
weeks after filming the episode the
reality stars husband Neil and daughter
Raquel opened up to et exclusively about
how important it was for ang to be there
for the taping they calls me and they
said you know do you think she could do
this as I think she needs to do this I
said she's sitting in this house she's
so depressed I said I think this is the
best thing you know yeah I think yeah I
think she it just comes with a couple
days forward what's up - I got we should
try on some outfits she felt so good you
know that - she actually went out that
night for dinner with the girls and hung
out afterwards Bobby for a couple drinks
which she wasn't supposed to be doing
but she didn't listen and I think she
went to a steak dinner with the girls or
the steak houses on that's a really I
gotta get going okay try to be a good be
as good as she's loved